As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh dear brothers and sisters. As
we watch what is unfolding today in
Gaza, we have to understand that
opposition is counting on us to lose
attention, to become fatigued, and to
move on with the new cycle. And just as
we can't allow them to dictate our
attention, we also can't allow them to
dictate the pace of our solidarity. And
part of that solidarity is going to be
there to rebuild Gaza, short-term,
long-term. I am proud to give my
support, my word of support to trusted
brothers and sisters in the United
Kingdom that have started a waqf, that
have started an endowment to make sure,
inshallah ta'ala, that we're there for
the long run. It's going to be
long-term, and we will not forget our
cause in Palestine. We will not forget
the cause of Al-Aqsa, and we will not
forget, bidhnillah ta'ala, our brothers
and sisters in Gaza. [music] Jazakum
Allahu khairan. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and citizens, dear
friends. Well, I didn't think this war
would get, um,
well, funnier on this level. You know,
it's fun and all, but people are losing
their lives. But, here is a video I I I
don't know how certain official it is,
but I've been seeing shared here and
there. So, let's watch a video of,
basically, US forces and American forces
attacking so-called planes and
helicopters, which are not helicopters
and, uh,
uh, well, not real helicopters and, uh,
fighter jets, but rather painted on the
floor by Iran. And they are seeing this
as a real image, and they're throwing
million multi-million pound, probably
maybe 20 to maybe 10 20 million pound
worth of bombs to get rid of them, but
they're just painting they're attacking.
Uh, war is deception. Breaking news in
Iran, as reported by Motaz Osman a short
while ago, Iranian deception tactics
reportedly made the Zionist and American
militaries look bad on the global stage.
It started when the Israeli terrorist
army and US aligned media proudly
released footage claiming a successful
strike inside Iran.
One clip showed what was presented as a
precision thermal strike and an Iranian
fighter jets.
The video was circulated as proof of
high-tech accuracy.
But, journalists and independent
analysts took the footage apart frame by
frame and uncovered a serious
technological embarrassment. When they
compared two thermal images, one taken
just before the strike, and another
exactly 1 second after, the so-called
fighter jet hadn't moved at all. No
displacement, no blast effect, nothing
you'd expect from a real explosion. So,
what happened?
It turns out there is no real fighter
jet. The target was reportedly a
sophisticated visual decoy, a 3D ground
rendering designed to fool area
surveillance and AI-based targeting
systems used by US and Israeli drones.
They mistook a cheap decoy for a real
aircraft and fired a missile costing
over a million dollars. This story is
now circulating in US and Israeli media
with critics citing it as evidence of
poor planning and blind alignment
between the Trump administration and
Benjamin Netanyahu, portraying Donald
Trump as reactive rather than strategic.
Makes you wonder how many other targets
were never real.
Good question, Motaz, and thank you for
this update.
So, there you go, um, brothers and
sisters. Uh, the helicopter, as you can
see, has been blown up. It's not even
moving, because it's a painting. Okay?
So, again, I don't know how authentic
that is, but let's go to Political
Alchemy, uh, which you can subscribe to
his channel, who which is
uh who is going to explain to us,
subhanallah, how
Iran is using strategic new technology
to bypass the Iron Dome and all those
kind of weapons. Here is what he
explains, and this is actually quite
profound, which shows Iran is actually
one step ahead of the game, just like in
my previous video about Professor Jing,
um, claiming and predicting that Iran is
going to win this war. And it looks
like, by the way, Political Alchemy, um,
explains this,
it looks like this is what's going to
happen, and it is literally penetrating
Israel. So, over the past day or so,
video images have come out showing this
new type of missile being deployed by
Iran.
These are ballistic missiles that,
before impact, as they approach their
target, separate into a number of
smaller cluster missiles. The advantage
is that they become almost impossible to
intercept, as you're no longer, you
know, intercepting just one missile, but
up to 80 smaller missiles.
Zionist forces have, you know, they've
acknowledged that Iran is using these
newer missile technology, and that at
least one missile was able to release
its cluster of missiles that hit Israel.
Iran is, and I think it's generally
become quite obvious, undertaking a
three-stage missile attack against US
and Israel. The first stage was to
target the early warning guidance
system, something I've mentioned in my
previous, you know, videos on this
topic. This is where they target US
military installations in Arab countries
that were used to detect, monitor, and
also track missiles, passing that
information to anti-missile systems
stationed in Israel. So, they are taking
them out to degrade the effectiveness of
American Israel's missile defense
system. The second prong in Iran's
missile attacks is to overwhelm and
deplete the interceptor missiles. They,
i.e., Iran, use older, less effective
missiles and drones to deplete these
interceptors. And the final stage is
then to use, you know, higher or some
more sophisticated types of missiles
with higher explosives and greater
technology to be able to reach and
locate its targets, whether in Israel or
American targets as well. So, the
cluster ballistic missile is almost an
advert to the potential of what's to
come, with Iran basically advertising
that they haven't used their full range
of missiles yet, leaving the more
sophisticated ones for later. As I
mentioned, and also many others have
also mentioned this now, this has become
a war of attrition. And there's still a
number of questions to see who will win
out in this war of attrition. One of
those questions is not just how many
missiles and, you know, missile
launchers does Iran have, but also how
many of these sophisticated missiles
with higher explosive yields do they
have? Often we hear claims that they
have tens of thousands of missiles and
drones, but that wouldn't translate into
tens of thousands of these hypersonic or
more sophisticated style of missiles.
And as I mentioned, it's attritional
because America is trying to take out as
many missiles as possible before their
own interceptor missiles completely run
out or become largely ineffective. This
is why America now is trying to escalate
its attacks against Iran to take out as
many missiles and missile launchers as
possible.
>> You're about to see, you know, we're
going to unleash change on these people
in the next few hours and days. You're
going to really begin to perceive a
change in the scope and in the intensity
of these attacks, as frankly the two
most powerful air forces in the world.
Well, I mean, I'm going to let you guys
watch the full video on Political
Alchemy, inshallah, but you can see,
subhanallah, war is deception. And the
Prophet told us about that, and strategy
is used. And the Prophet told us, "Do
not wish to meet the enemy, but when you
do,
be ready." Brothers and Allah subhana wa
ta'ala will aid. And like I said before
again, and I'll make my position clear
on the Iran thing, uh, Iran has killed,
um,
poo, maybe more Sunni Muslims than the
Zionists do. And they're both as evil as
each other. Um, but in this matter, like
I said before, I would rather side with
Iran than I would ever with Israel, even
though both have committed absolute
atrocities towards the Sunni Muslims in,
uh, Syria and in Gaza, brothers and
sisters, subhanallah. Um, so, again,
theologically, we might, uh, align with
them, uh, but the matter is we need to
be consistent morally, not
strategically. And you can go watch the
video, but it looks like in the coming
days that Iran might be winning this
war, you know? And the senators, they
are speaking, the Trump Donald Trump's
right-hand man, left-hand man, um,
subhanallah, are making it clear that,
"Oh, we're going to change the shift,
and etc." They are attacking everywhere.
They're attacking US embassies, Dubai,
Kuwait, Qatar, uh, you name it,
subhanallah. I even heard a a a bomb or
something like that got hit by
intercepted by Turkish, um, air forces.
It's escalating. It's escalating,
subhanallah. But, you can see there is a
shift happening. Maybe it is the
beginning of the end of the American
power. We don't know, but may Allah
subhana wa ta'ala protect everybody,
innocent people, in this war. Till next
time. As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi
wa barakatuh.